[Music]
hey
babe welcome to hey babe folks so Sal is
a little late he's gonna be coming in in
just one second there's a parking issue
on our block but he's finding a spot and
he's gonna come right in and it's going
to be great and I'm actually happy that
it worked out this way because there's
some stuff that I didn't want to let Sal
know
um that's why I had Dr Drew is came in
today Dr great the one and only Dr Drew
everybody knows everybody loves you know
his podcast on your mom's house you know
him from he might have been cats caught
sneaking out of your mom's house you
everybody loves Dr Drew if you're a mom
does not want to have sex with Dr Drew
then she's a man it's that was your
grandma so
I have Dr Drew in here now and I have
five minutes along with him before Sal
comes in I believe I came here to see
you not Sal so that's this is this ideal
this is perfect and it's perfect timing
yeah because as you can tell I am now
actively using cocaine again and we need
to speak to Dr Drew I have two problems
going on I'm actively because you always
seem like you're already on meth or
cocaine so it's really hard maybe are
you just one of these people that calm
down with the stimulants yes so that's
why you seem a little better today yes
you're actually less less edgy so less
sped up so that's what it is so cocaine
can be good good too
um so that's what Freud thought yeah I
know right until his friend got severely
addicted and he thought ah maybe I think
better this he actually developed
psychotic so I know well that that's the
interesting thing with drugs right is
like our people in the past use them a
lot for to do many good things yes
there's no such thing as a bad chemical
I mean that
literally there's just our relationship
with those chemicals and their potential
adverse effect and their potential
beneficial effects right you have to
understand the risk benefit and when to
deploy them and how to deploy them and
how long to deploy them that's all right
just then they can be mostly for good
yeah I think too you know that's why
you're using cocaine right now that's
why I'm using cocaine it's making me
feel better yeah I heard I just saw an
article the other day that there's no
known overdose of LSD you cannot take
enough of that yeah but but so what I
mean overdose is just one of the many
things that drugs can do to you right
there's no really there's really no
overdose on meth there's really no
overdose on cocaine I mean you could
really take so much you can precipitate
a heart attack but but that's really
hard to do most heart attacks and
strokes from cocaine occur with routine
use right excess use yeah somebody has a
heart attack people oh it was an
overdose no no that's just what cocaine
does right and the same thing with
benzodiazepine the Valium drugs sure
very hard to overdose on those unless
you add in some appropriate some Vicodin
then it's very easy yes as the Greeks
say nothing in excess everything in
moderation so if you're going to be
doing drugs moderate
um now you know I I forgive me if you've
spoken about this uh nauseam already but
I would assume you probably have with
other guests but I am a little bit late
to the game and I just listened to Joe
Rogan's RFK Junior podcast about the
vaccines and about all this information
now let me just say even though I know
that I look like I you know storm the
capital which I you know and I I was
there in spirit I am of God who's very
much in the middle I am not at all uh
one of these people that delves down
this conspiracy stuff I have an
education I you know my daughter's
Godfather is an emergency room doctor
use that education but okay yes exactly
I have you know yes I do live on Staten
Island where it's a bit of an island
mentality so people run rampant but I
try to take everything with a grain of
salt however after listening to rfk's um
uh Rogan interview Rogan interview
he does make and I thought kind of an
accurate assessment of the when he said
show me the 55 year old with a helmet
you know exhibiting autistic Behavior
show me the 55 Orthopedic algae which I
never thought of it that way right so
here's the thing about RPI I've
interviewed I have a show my wife would
kill me if I didn't mentioned the show I
have a show called ask Dr Drew it's on
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday at three
o'clock Pacific you can get you can see
it at drdu.tv you'll get announcements
there and I interviewed RFK Jr twice
uh and he was very interesting I
disagreed on some of his stuff his
assessment of AZT and fouchy and stuff
back in the day because I was I was in
the AIDS pandemic I was deep in it
treating patients oh I didn't say you
had AIDS no no no okay very interesting
I did but but I made it through you know
I was in the trenches with that so I had
some thoughts about some of the stuff he
was saying so I was pushing back on a
lot of the things he was saying but he
he like with that that particular show
by the way I'm here to promote ask uh
after dark which is your mom's house
thing right because I was a guest dog
were you a guest but but I want to talk
about this one because it's pertinent to
the RFK stuff I interview on this show
my wife produces this show and and I
interview anybody that was canceled
that's a professional it was canceled
and every single freaking one of them I
learned something I mean I didn't
necessarily agree with everything they
were saying but I learned something
important with each one and so people
like Peter McCullough and Robert Malone
and RFK Jr and all these people have
been vilified like cartoon characters
Jay bhattacharya who's this wonderful
man and a great professional consummate
teacher and and uh Aaron cariotti I mean
these are great professionals who were
condemned during this thing I got to
talk to these guys and I just got so
much from them and they have a lot to
teach us there's a lot of [__] went
wrong RFK taught me that there is a
crazy cozy relationship between The
Regulators at the FDA particularly in
the CDC to some extent and the Pharma
companies they just go back and forth
they hire each other back and forth so
of course their biases of course these
things bleed into the culture in both
the Pharma and on the regulator side
where they're not holding these drug
companies accountable the way they
should
then he showed me and taught me that in
the Reagan Administration they put in
place a essentially a waiver for
vaccines where they don't have to do
they don't have to do the usual testing
you don't have to do what we usually do
for drugs and he's saying look I just
want better more testing that's all I
want it's just these things to be tested
properly and I it's hard for me to argue
with that right now people that on the
other side of that go locally producing
these things forever and the testing it
goes speaks for itself
yes and no I'd still like it like for
the covet vaccine rushed out I
understand it was an emergency but now
let's get go back and do what we
normally do do the double blind Placebo
control or at least do uh just at least
to controlled uh forward-looking studies
with the controls we're not even doing
that yeah nothing like yeah like like I
just just the other day my one of my
kids was oh you know we took her to the
doctor and they wanted to give her the
hepatitis B vaccine and I'm like why
does she need that and then they also
tried to give her the Gardasil vaccine
and I'm like I understand why she would
need that yeah I understand HPV I get
that yeah but why now she's eight years
old well the thinking is it used to be
nine the thinking is that it has maximum
efficacy right okay but if I'm the
doctor and I'm working with a family and
a patient and you have some reason you
would like to wait we would do that
together right you know we'd wait till
when you think she's sexually active or
when you think you want to get that that
added benefit maybe it's 15 maybe it's I
don't I don't know but but this idea
that everything is handed from on high
is one of the most horrible things to
happen in medicine in history right that
what hap what should be properly trained
caring physician a well-informed
motivated patient and we together decide
what we're going to do every single case
right not following a pathway that's on
my electronic medical record which what
it is what it has become it's become
it's terrible I'm I'm embarrassed by my
profession I'm ashamed what happened
during covet it was disgusting and I've
had to apologize publicly because I feel
so sound like a podcaster I am a podcast
no I know it's like a doctor and a
podcaster so but uh so there you are you
brought it you sort of scratched that
edge right right yeah I I think too I
hope this isn't a comedy podcast no this
isn't funny hey if it was never funny
we've established that that's why rocket
money stopped uh advertising on us so so
I I think though you know when I listen
to this you know listen to the to the
RFK stuff and thought about it you know
you said something about
and I again I just never thought about
it this way he was like you know with
medicine a science I should say more
broadly science you question you should
be a healthy Society everything question
it all he said it's religion that you
could never question but it's been
reversed a bit now it's been bizarrely
like weirdly I it's never my career or
training is anything like this been the
case right it's always listen we called
outlying opinions really bizarre
outlying opinions interesting thank you
for stirring the pot thank you for
making us think things through we think
you're wrong we've thought it through
you're wrong but thank you right thank
you making us think it through yes not
this this notion of misinformation is
brand new and and dangerous seriously
dangerous yeah I think um when I listen
to it I just I just was like you know I
know that you know people talk about
vaccines all day and again I'm not a I'm
not a anti-vaxx person
I used to say that none of facts
available for my family facts but
there are people that have concerns and
they ought to be satisfied with better
testing and better decision making with
their doctors in concert with their
doctor not as opposed to their doctor
right yeah like have a conversation with
the my you know again you know a family
friend who's a doctor is like you should
go if your kid is sick you should be
going in there with everything you know
every symptom Googling stuff knowing
stuff and then just spit it out to the
doctor and let him or her decide what's
important and what's not and and it's
really important in terms of making that
a really positive interaction understand
whatever you Google whatever you've seen
the doctor's known that since second
year medical school right so don't think
you're teaching the doctor something but
it's letting the doctor know that you
understand the landscape of what's going
on so he or she doesn't have to educate
you about it so go ahead and say Here's
what I'm thinking here's what I'm saying
I worry about this here are the symptoms
and then just let the doctor use their
judgment right which is the only reason
you're going to a doctor right
everything else available you're going
for them to use their judgment in your
case which is something they've seen a
thousand times before but you are a
unique case that they are used use that
experience to apply their judgment and
human beings are human beings I get it I
always when I'm going to a doctor for
myself or really more specifically for
my children I always let them know in
the most respectful way knowing unders
letting them understand that I know that
they are the ones who make the decision
together together they are the experts
no but I I know that but I always make
sure that they know that I know at least
somewhat what I'm talking about so you
can't treat me or my kid on autopilot
remember what I said a caring properly
trained physician and an informed
motivated patient that's your best unit
nothing is more efficient than that
anything you pile on top of it screws
with it got it now how do you know if
you have a bad doctor
finger in the ass when you're going in
for a tennis elbow yeah it's a little
bit of a concern or if they'd yeah uh we
could go a lot of places with this yeah
not you know they could also it's not
out of the realm of possibility that
they're you know swollen prostate is you
got a screen for this stuff yeah you
want to make sure you get what you got
the patient at hand you got to do you
got to do so so before you see somebody
Chris come in you're like it's got to be
a problem there and and uh you if
they're not listening to you that's a
sign that something's up right right and
it just all they have to do is listen
carefully the one misconception that
people have is that the doctor needs to
spend a lot of time oftentimes we don't
we literally we know when you walk in
the room we know what's going on right
we know we've seen it a million times we
can literally smell it and we know it
and so the time spent is not the issue
but but once we smell what's going on we
just sit and listen carefully and that
should confirm what we instinctively
thought and then you go on about your
business but that shouldn't take long do
you in fact a lot of doctors sit and
just listen for five more minutes just
to satisfy the patients right because
we've already decided what we're going
to do they know what it is right away no
because we know we just made it a
million times before I wanted to ask you
do you with all this how many years have
you been practicing medicine now I
became a physician in 84 been practicing
like 87.88 wow okay so long time yeah so
do you in all kinds of settings too oh
my God I've seen so much so do you feel
now like has it gone to the point where
you can now not always I understand but
certain cases throughout your career
well you've been able to look at the
patient yeah and know that there's
something seriously wrong before they
say anything before you see any tests
just something you came to explain was
just intuition of being an expert
there's many flavors and versions of
that yes for sure yeah including you
know I worked with drug I had ran a big
drug unit for 20 years too and so
including
interpreting what drug addicts are
telling me right you know what I mean uh
I you know I I tell a story all the time
this is just an example this intuition
stuff that got I had to get it honed for
drug addicts
um the guy this guy comes in this guy
who really cared about it seen him like
three times and he kept going out
relapsing this time he came in after the
really serious near-death experience
and he's sitting in a chair across from
me sobbing he's like oh my God I'm done
with this I can't stand it I'm gonna die
I I'm so destroyed all this distress and
I could feel he was in pain man as a kid
I was worried about concerned about but
because I trust whatever my instinct is
I just let whatever
comes out of my mouth come out and I
don't even think about it when I'm
sometimes dealing with addicts and I
just looked at the kid and I went you're
so full of [__] I didn't know what the
[__] is going on anymore and he stopped
crying and he looked at me and I thought
oh what have I done he's gonna punch me
or something and he went I know how did
you know I can't tell which real it's
not anymore I can't I can't tell I'm so
full of crap my does the disease makes
me I I don't know and I said well I can
feel I feel what's real in you I see it
I hear it and we can and we started
working together right then we were able
to work you couldn't even really
articulate it with words it was just a
feeling it was first I received
something and then I just trusted what
was going to come out of my mouth I
really didn't even think about it yeah
it was just like came out and I was like
oh that's the thing about intuition and
gut feeling and I'm sure you could
explain the science of it way better but
I mean you know really when you're
feeling something when you're like
trusting your gut and that intuition
you're really feeling like millions of
years you know of evolution and sales
and you're like 100 it's it's literally
it it is a million years of years of
evolution of the brain body right it is
your bodily based experience in this
clinical setting a thousand times that
teaches not just your cognition but your
body right what's the feelings of what's
going on and so you can it's a more
holistic kind of experience you're
receiving you know the patient's telling
me one thing I'm listening I hear it I
believe he's in distress I had another
my whole body had a different experience
and I let it happen right it's
interesting it's very interesting
because because I think a lot of us and
because of societal pressures we a lot
of times don't trust our gut we go with
whatever our parents want to do our
friends want to do it
what a t-shirt
salvocanos walked around with the Rosie
Perez t-shirt
that outfit I love I know this is we're
actually we're having a blast I mean
maybe go back out and repark your car or
something or yeah
we're talking about drug intuition we're
talking about RFK we're talking about
where Dr Drew is is going we're we're
still Robert Kennedy we're talking about
that all right yeah we're doing the show
a bunch of times oh wow I was drunk to
this day and never did I think that I'd
be uh coming to our meeting late in any
way shape or form but uh it is can we
just talk I just want to talk about
Sal's got a nice fresh haircut in the
back it looks awesome everybody tapered
very well lovely yeah
best haircut yeah that's exactly right
Union look your teeth look the
straightest they've looked well if I
could walk into a room and receive
compliments like this
this podcast sponsored by betterhelp
thank you to the good people that better
help if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try entirely
online it's designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with licensed therapist and
switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge uh better help let
therapy be your map with better help
it's awesome and we got a nice discount
for you for listening to the show the
good people have better help have given
you some money down some money off which
we really appreciate go to
betterhelp.com hey babe today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash hey babe 10 off your
first month
this episode is sponsored by Blue chew
Let's Talk About Sex guys remember the
days when you were always ready to go
now you can increase your performance
and get that extra confidence in bed
listen up bluechoo.com Bluetooth is a
unique online service that delivers the
same ingredients as VI Viagra
sorry you've been in Europe for a while
Viagra Cialis and Levitra but in
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you can take them anytime day
or nights you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arrives that
smart is it's all done online no visits
a doctor's office does it work do you
think you need to try it for free for a
month and see you're gonna love it you
could be missing out on some of the best
sex of your life Bluetooth wants you to
help you have better sex discover your
options at bluetooth.com chew it and do
it that's right Bluetooth tablets are
made in the USA and prepared and shipped
directly to our industry package and
right now we've got a special deal for
our listeners my friend try Bluetooth
free when you use our promo code hey Abe
at checkout just pay the five dollar
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
hey babe to receive your first month uh
sorry visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank Bluetooth for sponsoring
the podcast my mother wanted to ask and
Sal's mother also text me want to ask
was just a simple question for Dr Drew
what's your secret
that's what my mom wanted to know that's
what our moms want to know what's your
secret for what my mom wanted to know
and Sal's mom wants to know how you're
so handsome so hold on I also want to
know so yeah so all right to be honest
it was our fathers who wanted to know
what's your secret what's your regimen
what's yours what's my regimen because
you just I mean look at him you look you
got the veins bulging out of the muscles
you look good are you fasting are you
working on three to five times a week I
know your way around the dumbbell if I'm
being honest so so so
uh I used to work out uh I used to I
lifted weights my whole life right I I
worked out have you seen the Arnold
documentary yes yes didn't wasn't the
best thing ever I loved it
carrying that dude very inspiring and
I've actually spoken to him before and
it's like when you speak to Arnold it's
like speaking to somebody pretending to
be Arnold right
yeah it is concerning but his first Mr
Universe competition when you saw him on
the stage with the guy next to him yeah
second place that was Bill Pearl Bill
Pearl had a gym in Pasadena when I was a
kid growing up and he set me up training
when I was like 16 for football when I
was playing High School football and I
trained like all the way through medical
school and just kind of kept it going
and I you know have a now oh there there
let's see you looking at Bill Pearl
you're looking at Arnold that's Bill
next to him the color picture the second
one wow yeah
everybody at this level is experimenting
with with steroids experimenting
you are using oh the amount of stuff
they use is incredible experiment is how
much I can do right experimenting is
that we keep a secret exactly what the
what the recipe is here
um but so so I got into weightlifting
very early and often and I loved it and
it was set up now it was in my my garage
I do it all the time but now but here's
the deal as I've gotten older my
shoulders are Mass am I going to get you
kicked off YouTube by using the f word
no no no no they are a disaster they
look great well I can't I can't push the
weights I used to like anything like
that so I've switched my whole
um so we can get him paid for something
I actually got paid to represent this V
shred operation who switched me to more
intense really good program that I've
been following and I feel much better
doing that my shoulders are better I can
do more and so it's as you get older you
got to go more towards intensity and
less towards that kind of satisfaction
do you think there's a number in mind or
it's just trust your body once your body
starts to get to a point I'll be 65 in a
couple of months
I mean imagine this is because look at
this is what our 65 year olds look like
but a 65 year old like think about my
grandmother with 61. I lose 180 years
looking at Adam Adam and I you know Adam
I still have a podcast together we do
all the time and we watch Love Boat
every week and do a little recap of it
yeah oh yeah they look 65 when they're
like 30. when they're 45 they look like
our 65 or 70 year olds and 65 year olds
like have a character they're like an
old person right they have to play an
old person what do you think it is do
you think it's new proper nutrition and
Healthcare so I'll tell you what I focus
on i i as I've gotten older uh sleep for
sure I mean I try to get out of sleep
every night I used to do four or five
hours when I was practicing full-time
and stuff it was crazy there's no way to
get around that but you couldn't uh no I
couldn't and just watched a master class
on sleep and I I know it's important but
I didn't realize how
I was feeling my senses you know my
sense when young brains and young bodies
you can abuse I'll sum the whole thing
up though get sleep yeah I guess you get
eight hours but some people don't need
it I understand but a lot of people do
and so so young people you can abuse
your body you can I mean I I didn't
sleep blah blah blah but as I got older
I started and I could see it and so I
started I'm gonna focus on this uh you
asked if I'm fat I'm strangely fasting
right this week I'm doing intermittent
fasting because I'm trying to get my I'm
trying to get my weight down a little
bit I'll do one week on one week I was
on Carnivore for four years and but not
eating in any type of fasting window
just only eating carnivore meat for four
years and I would just eat like crazy
whatever I want whatever and I gained
about seven pounds on that one but it
was good it was good yeah it was not bad
weight but I was still I was up a bit
and um and so I'm trying to get I'm
trying to get more appropriate for my
age you know leaner so what are you in
16 hour window 18 hours you know
just whenever yeah from like you start
eating at noon stop eating at like eight
you know yeah you can see a little
different because I mean I'm on weird
time zones and stuff all the time and we
go out all the time so I'll like make it
to like you know four in the afternoon
eastern time and I'll have some bone
broth or something or maybe an omelette
or something and then we'll go out to
dinner you know that's got it right
right so you're still well under 2 000
calories and all that I'm probably 2500
calories a day because at dinner you're
going with but I want to move yeah but
I'm careful I'm really careful with what
I eat I I don't eat I don't eat carbs I
don't eat I try not to Sugar so I binged
two nights ago uh what's your binge tell
me what your benches you know the thing
if I could be the things I've had to cut
out to to do the diets problem because
because my I look my biology is my
genetics are not good right uh my my dad
got looking weight and bad vascular
disease large vessel vasculinity some of
you don't think about what that's his
aorta was a mess and he was throwing
clots to his head and his kidneys really
bad I know and so so I got on I got on
statins when I was like 35 I'm like I
don't want anything to do that and my
and my cardiac calcium score is 0.0 so I
seem to have pushed this stuff back but
I'm pretty clear that ayuda has this LP
little a thing or apple b problems Rita
Peter attia's book
um he's the best he's all over the zero
fasting app that I use right uh he um
zero fasting zero yeah he doesn't like
fasting because you get lose too much
muscle with the fasting well no but I
mean not something
I'm saying well I do this no no the zero
fasting app the name of the app is
called zero okay yeah that that's the
app that he's on okay he's a little
worried about fasting these days because
of the potential loose muscle but I say
you just worked through you pushed
through it
when he talks about when he talks about
a fast he's talking about prologue I
think if you're eating in a from you
know 16 to if you're eating
I do it because I have an appetite
problem I once I start eating I cannot I
just sing it sister go I I go man and
especially if I eat carbs I really go
yeah and so he that book I live is the
best description the best sort of lay
persons
um what's the word I'm looking for sort
of uh explanation of lipid metabolism
I've ever seen Peter's so clear so good
and uh I look like that an easy a fun
read
students but then I'm going to read a
book about like I mean it's like talking
to Peter he feels like you feel like
he's talking to you it's in his voice he
does Peter attia does a great job from
you know again watching him on the app a
great job of putting everything that's
highly scientific in layman's terms okay
it really really does an awesome
everybody's Hawkeye when this guy's
gonna pass because he's got to talk the
talk and walk the walk Peter well he met
his thing so anytime in the next 30
years it's a disappointment so I was
pimping him the other day I was pimping
there's all these longevity hacks which
I word I hate but like metformin and
things like that I'm like I'm a computer
about that what about this what about
that finally he turns me he goes
vigorous exercise vigorous exercise
that's it that's the one thing and then
your muscle mass later in life like 70s
and 80s yeah adequate muscle mass that's
it those are the two things yeah like
when you start chasing ozempics and this
and that it's like you're all you're
trying to do is get around your body
how's it in you all you have to do is
like you said the vigorous exercise like
this kid who died unfortunately this big
influence of all those steroids
what was his name
he he was shredded ripped amazing and
then he dropped dead at 30. now who
knows really what happened but he was
saying he his last one of his last weeks
of posting was talking about how we
should do at my shoulders I can't do
that
I've never seen that move done before no
it's it's still too yeah
against him he said he took way too much
testosterone replacement yeah yeah I saw
him saying that they say how he passed
and by the way I love the way he called
it testosterone replacement yeah it's
like Arnold's saying experimenting I
took testosterone replacement should be
just restoring to normal he died
I saw some weird stuff of him have him
having thrombocytopenia and these other
things and some of the stuff was has
been associated with vaccine reactions I
know and so it's like I don't know how
much of this is that and the scientific
conclusions online about a month ago
that had gave me a full-blown anxiety
panic attack yeah you were in discussion
with a couple of other people and uh
about that about the uh possible side
effects of vaccinations and uh I'm not
the guy that needs to hear that nor do I
need to hear it around 3 A.M maybe I was
sweating bullets I was up until about
six I'm shaking it off he don't know
[__]
don't know [__] I've been searching
online
for that that like uh why don't you ask
me whatever it raised in your mind what
because I'm I'm generally can you give
me a full like let me give me a full
physical right now on camera
can you look into my soul and tell me
anything and unfortunately that's what's
happening already
you don't want to go there trust me so
but but uh look I vaccinated all my
elderly patients I boost all my elderly
patients uh once we got to the um the uh
Omicron boosters I wasn't quite sure
what we were doing we didn't have the
data so I advise them kind of hold off
unless they wanted it then I said okay
go take it yeah and there should be an
xbb.1.15 coming and again elderly people
these vaccines saved their lives clearly
worth the risk
28 year old male no risk from homicron I
mean none
why give that guy something that may
have a slight risk that's the part I'm
struggling the risk is remote I mean
it's not a big deal but it's me doing
something to you and giving you risk
where you really don't have a risk
that's the part I struggle sure sure
yeah right well that's what that whole
RFK was about well his thing without
better testing better testing I'm like
yeah if I had better taste testing I
could know the risk reward for that
population right we don't have the right
testing yeah yeah it's where do you
stand where do you stand then on like
because you send like young bodies can
abuse them where do you stand on like
short-term steroid use like short-term
or anabolic steroids or short-term HGH
okay so so
short term you know so I grew up today I
worked out around all those guys right
right uh and they were always bugging me
for stuff too so I knew what they were
doing you know I knew they would they
would go hey that was back when it was
all very secretive right because once I
got a license they were like hey I need
this I'm like
and and in their late 30s and stuff a
lot of them started dying and I was like
well this is not good I was worried
about this and what was the cause of
death typically different things
you can only get so ripped they don't go
there they don't have a read that far in
the book yes so it's hard hard attack
Strokes kidney failure liver failure it
just was all over the place uh and
vascular disease of all sorts Doug
bergnoli was a friend of mine he just
died recently in his 50s but like a guy
like Schwarzenegger is alive and healthy
was doing all this yeah but I'd be right
so that so people look at guys like that
and go well what's how did he get away
with it some of it is you know he had
valvular heart disease and stuff he had
remember he had a big chest surgery and
a revision of that surgery too it came
out in the documentary and uh and so
he's been under a lot of medical
supervision so I'm guessing that's that
whatever he did to himself they've been
kind of working on that right for years
number one number two some people can
withstand all that right not everybody's
the same in terms of the risk of doing
something like this back to the point if
if I didn't have prostate cancer I would
be taking testosterone replacement I'm
sure I'm 100 sure of that right but I
have prostate cancer so I can't do that
uh if I were younger now given what we
know about the cycling and you know this
kind of short-term stuff and let's say I
was 28 right got to be so tempting if
you see so tempting but I don't think I
would do it because you because you
still do believe even with all the
testing and knowledge we have there
still will be long-term impact I worry
about my genetics bad vascular disease
my family I have prostate cancer in my
family right I might have accelerated
all the stuff that I was able to kind of
avoid and do good with one more exercise
question so I'm a cancer patient too on
top of my routine I have process
no Cancer's here this is a hey babe
exclusive I know you haven't mentioned
that publicly no you're not talking
about it yeah I heard it here first he
shows he shows pictures of his open
[__] going to his prostate oh that's
that's how there's no I'm trying to say
there it's God oh yeah I know we have
now when I show them is prostate and now
when you eject when you have an orgasm
no no ejaculate wow prostitution creates
the fluid so you have no prostate you
have no fluid amazing amazing very clean
very clean appreciates it very much
because Schwarzenegger and and I think
it was Weidner Joe Weidner they kind of
pioneered weiner sorry they they uh you
know thick and wide yeah they they
um kind of pioneered the way that we all
were taught to work out three four sets
yes well it was actually Bill Pearl oh
Numero Uno put somebody back on his name
bro put some respect on it
no because it means number one yeah
because not everyone speaks Spanish as
our listeners I just want to be clear go
ahead what's under your hat today by the
way I'm wondering what's under there
how's your haircut imagine it's a gun
yeah now did that outfit did that outfit
come
as a set this is a set yeah you didn't
go around until you found matching
things you said and I walked two blocks
in New York City and nobody even cared
because they were like this is just the
way this guy looks oh New York City
there's a bathing suit they sell weird
sets like that all over New Orleans they
do this in New Orleans no I got I think
I got it on Amazon okay I honestly think
we should go back to the way children
dress like I would have been like you
know what I'm uh how the hell the man
are you I'm a 38 biological I'm 400
months old and your whole outfit's on
hang up by month yes she's going to the
store be like what do you got for a 400
month old and you take that whole thing
with the hat on the hanger and
everything I love that I do like Carter
should be like making an adult line I
love it yeah that's actually a great
idea that's a business idea write it
down yeah
but I would do it take the guesswork out
but the question I have because I know
Bill Pearl is writing it down
[Laughter]
so but my quest
about about the bill Pearl
Schwarzenegger weiner thing four sets
eight reps but the guy but before that
there was Mike Meltzer who his whole
thing was you know melter I've heard the
name so his whole thing was and he
supposedly tank Sinatra told me about
him and his whole thing was he got
menser sorry Mike Mentor his whole thing
was one set or two sets Max two complete
absolute failure spend 25 minutes in the
gym and you look like that and that's
how he trained his he won the Mr Olympia
he was the first guy to get a perfect
score then all his uh uh I can tell you
for sure that is not how he trained you
think I mean he was advising other
people to train that way but that is not
how he trains but you don't think the
whole idea of going and by the way one
set to failure and then take 10 days off
he was only in the gym four times a
month no way just can't work no way
no no this is like that's what I think
he's selling you know workout people
anybody not into that stuff into looking
like that I would think oh my God I
would look like him what 10 days I'm I'm
in where do I pay up that's right
because it's hard work it's daily work
you can take some days off for sure do
you think working out your body seven
days a week is the way to go you think
every day a little bit of exercise I I
for me that's important but I think
five out of seven days you have to yeah
you try to get in every day I tried
mostly because you know why
you know why I do it every day because I
only do uh four reps of that either yeah
because my schedule routinely gets away
from me and then there are days when I
can't go and so I just try to go every
day I can and then I'm feel better about
those days when I lose lose it and I
can't go okay interesting yeah all right
babe every time I travel you know me I
like going on history tours I like going
on walking tours I like going any type
of tour correct when I go anywhere I
send you a picture of Des Moines capital
building because I just knew you'd like
to see you know I like to see it and I
said I've been on a tour there I went on
a walking tour and you said really what
company do you use Viator Viator is
probably my favorite website the
favorite app I have on my phone Viator
they literally when any anything you're
looking to do is a new city all around
the world viator's got you throw some
stats on that 300 over 300 000 bookable
travel experiences in over a hundred and
yep countries yeah they offer everything
from simple tours to Extreme Adventures
and all the niche interesting stuff in
between Viator is the place to go to
book memorable travel experience I went
when I went to London I used Viator I
went on the Jack the Ripper walking tour
was the best tour I've ever taken in my
life anywhere in the world since ever oh
yeah in shortage shortage yeah yeah we
went to the shortage Soho House got a
little got a little meat and veg yeah
and then we walked around this tour and
Viator and it's always a great host they
make it so always a great tour guide
they make it so easy to find where you
have to meet they send you an email the
night before a text a day of Viator is
awesome and when you book a travel
experience with Viator there's always
flexibility and support with free
cancellation payment options and 24 7
service and I can attest that that is
100 Trail so download the Viator app now
and use code Viator one zero for ten
percent off your first booking one app
over 300 000 experiences you'll remember
do more with Viator
listen bird dogs yeah I love their
clothes they make you look good I know I
agree I know that you do hands and
shorts I love it yeah I got some stuff
from them and I love its quality made
and it fits really good you know it's
the same thing as as uh Lululemon but
they fit way better it's like it's the
same exact thing that Lululemon does
with the kind of underwear built to the
shorts but bird dogs is better I promise
you it's better I agree bird dog stretch
khaki shorts are designed to fit Slimmer
through the thigh and leg giving you a
truly sculpted look is shorts are the
exact same thing uh but better than
their competitors they fit way better
than regular shorts and uh that are made
of those stiff like like maybe these
those hard cotton dots and bird dogs
they have the anti-stink sweat wicking
fabric that keeps you cool and dry all
day long and just smell it fresh baby
nice you never know when you have to
have your nuts out show yourself
yeah all you got to do if you want a
discount go to birddogs.com hey babe and
enter the promo code hey babe for a free
Yeti style tumbler with your order
that's birddogs.com hey babe promo code
hey babe you're gonna get the free Yeti
style tumbler you do not want to take
your bird dogs off we promise you they
sent me that Yeti tumbler it's awesome
we love you bird dogs love you babe I
got a brand new hour of stand-up
material I'm filming a special for it in
December so come see it live before then
we got Atlantic City New Jersey The
Borgata August 18th 19th September 5th
and 6th Irvine California September 8th
Portland September 9th Seattle and then
of course September 22nd and 23rd we
have Radio City Music Hall in New York
City and the theater at MSG
um and then September 30th is Las Vegas
Nevada and then all my October November
December dates are at chrisdcomedy.com
get ticket wikis
what's up guys you got one last weekend
to see the Impractical Jokers first leg
of the tour uh July next week July 27 28
29 we're in Nashville Indianapolis and
St Louis
impracticaljokerslive.com the second leg
of the tour is not happening until
January or so in 2024. in January
speaking of January 2024 is the
Impractical Jokers cruise that we are
throwing with Eric Andre the Cruz is
going to be insane it's the fifth one if
you've been on it I know I'll see you if
you've never been on it you gotta come
it's a Once in a Lifetime party you can
get uh signed up at get shipfaced
cruise.com and then your boy right now
is filming a special in December in
Chicago and my tour kicks off in two
weeks uh and I'm gonna be all over town
go to savocano comedy.com for tickets
we're starting off which is a Hartford
uh Syracuse and Albany funny bones and
then we are moving along to Bowling
Green and uh Illinois and
um so on and so forth just check it out
it's all out now and I don't even know I
think there was a pre-sale I don't have
all the information but if you just go
to salvolcano comedy.com you can locate
everything and then buy some merch I got
merch taste made Scott merch hey baby
has merch I'm done talking
yeah I feel like um I feel like uh you
know bodybuilders again shut off aboard
tank Sinatra he's a bodybuilder and he
says what he does once a year is you
know train he beats the [__] out of his
body and then he takes three weeks off
oh yeah those guys you a lot of those
guys do that but he says what's
interesting on the 18th or 19th of the
21 days yeah he said like clockwork
people start to tell me even though
mentally he's like I feel like [__]
because you look the best you've ever
looked and the most pumped he's ever
looked because because we forego the in
his opinion and this is what mentzer
said a lot of people forego how
impactful rest is nobody correct however
the uh I had a couple of guys I knew
back in the day that a long time ago
that did that and they came back after
like a three vacation I'm like Jesus you
look great and they're like I don't know
when whenever they would say I don't
know I have no idea about it that was
sort of code for oh they're still taking
the steroids right
way you know uptick uptick on the
protein intake no carbs the dieting
there is continued for sure
this is The X Factor with all this yes
yes let me let me throw it the other way
like yeah before you get a haircut
before you had a person that did your
hair like you ever remember we used to
just going randomly whatever and then
you walk into a place like when I was
little you used to go to the mall not
everyone is as bougie as you people
still do that well you know what I'm not
bougie I just found a guy that did it
right and I stuck with him but when you
don't have it yeah
you don't have when you don't have that
guy like when we were little we used to
go to the mall the mall Supercuts lemon
tree was was insane it was just they
would give scissors to anybody in that
doesn't matter and you ever go to get
your hair cut and the guy cutting your
hair the wound cut your hair their hair
is awful and you're like what am I
getting myself into if they can't keep
their own hair tight and nice well then
I'm not gonna cut them off but seeing a
physician who's fat and smoking or
whatever this is what I'm getting at
that was my lead and then thank you for
that uh I have a doctor one of my
doctors is is is is is is caused from
concern because his weight and his whole
his whole General is they're like Beyond
like they're real fat his his yeah he or
she's I would argue that they could
physically that could still make great
decisions and still be a great doctor I
would agree it's almost like saying
you're you're your oncologist has to
have cancer they don't they can still
make great decisions they're highly
trained they they don't take care of
themselves that's their problem that
doesn't affect their functioning as a
doctor right right okay right but you
would wish that they would take care of
themselves
of course but it's not that important
for the kind the stuff they're doing
typically I always wonder about like it
doesn't matter if your immunologist has
AIDS or not right look they have AIDS
they still have the same studies it's
the same thing and if you're and if
you're I'm not treating your
hypertension or something if I'm a fat
it doesn't matter right right right okay
okay but it might bias how I address you
if you had a problem like what I have
that's where it could get weird right
okay so if I'm fat and you're like I'm
not taking care of myself and you're not
taking care of myself I might be a
little uncomfortable going hey we got
you got to do this now the way sure now
my I hope what I would do if I were that
doctor is go hey I have this problem too
it's really tough for me I can't seem to
get it together but as your doctor I
gotta advise you you got to do it okay
and do better than me that could be very
impactful right yeah yeah that could be
that could be even more important what
do you think as a doctor two-fold
question what do you think as a doctor
now with all our advancements in Ai and
all that stuff where do you see the
impact of that happening in medicine and
also second what do you think as being a
very intelligent man what do you think
or you know person I want to assume what
do you think
um he doesn't have a prostate what do
you think that's just part of a person
but but I don't know if a man without a
process I don't know if it's technically
a man I just don't know but as someone
who's prostate list what do you think
what do you think that we are getting
wrong right now as a society in medicine
and stuff that we're getting wrong that
in a hundred years those people will
look back and be like look at how
[__] they were as if somebody from
the 16th the smartest man the doctor
Drew of the 1600s thought that you know
still smarter than us they thought that
right but they thought that the sun was
you know they thought the the Earth was
uh the sun was going around the earth
yeah you know the top people and they
were not bad people they just didn't
have information
as usual it's we these things come out
of the blue and surprise us right so
it's very hard to speculate about these
things but the one thing that has
bothered me these days is and you sort
of open this this question by bringing
up the AI thing uh and you and I before
Sal came in and ruined the conversation
we were talking about we were talking
about the Instinct and the importance of
instinct I think that is being minimized
to a point that people are going to go
oh my God what happened to that
profession what did they do to that
profession during those years until they
brought back the caretaking the
instincts the things that we really need
to do the job of for taking care of
other human beings the fact that that
has been marginalized I literally I I
listed on Twitter spaces sometimes and
people like well the science says and
what do you say when the FDA tells you
that the Ft has nothing to do with the
practice of medicine there's never I
trained Physicians for years I never
said what's the fda's opinion on this
ever right ever if the FDA determines
under what conditions a company can
bring a drug or a product to Market
nothing to do with what our decision
making is of as Physicians that create
some liability you know narrower
liability sort of avenues for us but
that's it that's right yeah the point is
the Drug Administration is listening and
we know that they are we know that they
are back off yeah well they have nothing
to do with us they have zero uh same
thing with a CDC CDC is just a group
that advised us with data that we do the
practice when I train Physicians we're
not talking about the CDC of the FDA
ever right so it's crazy that the the
public thinks that that somehow is the
standard upon which physician decision
making is is uh made clear but so that
is there's that and that's sort of a
goofy thing but there there are going to
be things we are doing like serotonin
reuptake Inhibitors and statins that we
have worries about we have concerns
about these things I take a satin every
day but they're we're gonna stand
cholesterol medicine
um but there are things about these
sorts of routine medication we use that
one day will be looked at like very
sideways like like that was causing more
harm than good but you know they once
thought this was a useful thing I mean
just look at the suicide rate in this
country right now right how much good
are we doing with ssris really right
right I mean it's it's sort of there's a
lot of group thinking medicine and
there's a lot of uh
frankly uh the the drug companies and
how these things are distributed have a
major impact on what we do yeah and so
those kinds of things will be looked at
very uh negatively I think right well
just like just like how they use you
know back in the day you know they would
advertise smoking cigarettes people
thought smoking cigarettes was a healthy
option to de-stress you or whatever that
is like whatever
so it's similar I think too I think too
um you know like with AI and all these
advancements I think you might be able
we might write and you obviously the
expert in the next 25 years might be
able to pinpoint a lot of problems that
are going to happen for people almost in
utero and correct them from the
beginning right like there's a world
where I heard people might be living to
a hundred and the person that's going to
make it to 150 might be alive right now
um it's possible go go meet him go go
meet a 95 year old right there is there
is a inevitable fall off that happens at
a certain point
how many years you want to live honestly
I think before you tap out honestly
Holds Barred honestly I wear a cup I
think I can beat up more 95 year olds
than toddlers I think that if you put me
in a room with 100 toddlers I'd lose
quicker than 195 Euros yeah toddler's
bounce yeah yeah
versus a decreased bone masses uh yeah
yeah it's ours I have a question for you
oh yeah you've seen a lot of people
leave their body I'm sure yeah so do you
believe in ghosts yeah not at all no but
I've seen some weird stuff I mean I mean
death is a very I mean one thing I
realized when I started practicing
internal medicine is like oh okay when
everybody else all the Specialists and
everybody are done with them they send
it back to us to die always and uh so a
lot of death it's a very specific thing
for me but I've seen some weird stuff
I've seen some things like you know this
one guy was dying actively and he was
delirious and you know sort of
encephalopathic we call that
and uh he all of a sudden at like 11
o'clock in the morning sat up in bed and
went I have an appointment with Jack
Smith at one ten don't let me forget and
he went back into this delirium and his
family reported this to me and they go
Jackson it's been dead for years it's so
weird 110 guy died
yeah right when he said right when he
said he had the appointment
I always got disappointments
do you think then the energy goes on to
something else I know no idea there's no
right question I I when I start thinking
about stuff like that I immediately go
into you know quantum physics and stuff
and the nation of temporality and time
and what that is even but it does and
again this could just be the product of
the documentaries that we watch about
near-death experiences but everybody who
you at least you see on TV or the
internet who has a near-death experience
says that they no longer fear death and
they felt an insane calmness I don't
know if there's other stories where it's
not so there's two things about that
there is a common experience of dying
white light feeling like you're around
your early family members and stuff like
that your brain is probably doing that
my wife had it when after she delivered
our triplets she went to shock had the
white light experience it's sort of a
what your brain does when it's in shock
and you know it makes it after triplets
I would have lost State either I'd like
get this thing
and and so yeah Bud Light
that's very funny
so uh you derailed me this is
why your brain's doing so the white
light and the right and the wife that
doesn't have to be a metaphysical
experience that could be something the
brain does right at the end of things
because after that there seems to be not
much you know nothing after that so I
don't know but I mean I don't know
that's what your wife had the triplets
she had a near-death experience yeah
what happened
essentially they she had a Bell's Palsy
her blood volume expanded so much that
the your seventh cranial nerve your
facial nerve comes out in a thing these
little tiny holes in the skull and it
expanded to the pointer blood volume
that it cut off the blood supply or
facial nerve so it died and she
developed Bell's palsy and they put her
on steroids in case it was a virus you
know try to bring the face back which it
did uh but then they didn't give her
stress steroids after she delivered
three circulatory systems right and she
went into shock like full shock and
almost died like right that you were
there yeah and I was like so she was
dying in front of you I knew something
was terribly wrong and you take over
right there well I ran in and grabbed
the chart and the nurses started yelling
at me I'm like this I just [__] up
giving her stress steroids good I called
the neurologist and I go this is a you
know 30 something year old woman who's
been on serious for last month in shock
not being able to stressed steroids
because the gynecologists don't think
about these things
along those lines though they know they
they're thinking about other stuff and
the neurologists frankly should have
remember it but but he wasn't around at
that stage I brought him back you know
and so yeah gynecologist or the
gynecologist and Obsession are in the
worst position in the world because the
surgeons don't think they're really they
don't think they're good surgeons and
the internists don't think they're good
medical people because they don't they
do [__] like this all the time and yet
they're experts in what they have to
worry about which is you know the baby
the baby vaginal Health yeah but but so
do you actually think if you weren't
there she might have might have done who
knows it was not good that happens a lot
with my family where I've had discovered
[__] and and gone uh we're gonna do
something here my wife talks about this
all the time that this stuff that I've I
got to marry a doctor because I need I
need the safety net I need to safety now
we all need it now I mean I am a
physical therapist I'm a podcast partner
so I can help out you're my first call
um but let me ask you this did you have
triplets old school way just a shot was
in the early 90s there was a lot of
super multiples because they hadn't
figured out how to give people two or
one yet so they'd always implant five
embryos if they could and they would end
up with three and four what happened
with octo mama
she's apparently doing really well
I forget I knew her I used to interview
her and work with her and stuff the
human body consists well obviously but
how does it sustain hate circles it's
unbelievable
women are tough what's going on I went
into the Wadi Rum desert I tell you
about this desert thing I got Special
Forces uh I went into the Wadi Rum
desert in Jordan with a group of uh
celebrities and we had our ass kicked by
uh Navy SEAL trainers that's a show on
Netflix or something it's on Fox Fox
yeah and uh there we are uh just getting
our just ass handed to us with six of us
ended up in the hospital within three
days because of what I was in the
hospital because of dehydration heat
exhaustion I was Jamie Lynn Spears
literally saved my life literally you
almost died on that I was I was like
confused and out of it and she grabbed
me took me to the medic and I was I was
trying to hide it because I didn't want
to know there we go wow that's the they
would dive out of helicopters their
amped falling out of a helicopter was it
fun it was was fantastic I didn't do it
again uh yeah well uh it was it was the
group of us
the group was it was insane the group of
us got so bonded up that were like talk
all the time to this day is inseparable
right now and well Mike Piazza was in
the groove I just talked to him
yesterday I figured you guys were like
Mike and uh so it's it it was just a lot
of fun but I you know I ended up in an
ICU the next day wow and um in the
middle of the Jordanian desert that was
my job
but the whole production on hold then uh
no no no they kept going I was just sent
off to the hospital wow did that hurt
when you fall we brought two and a half
stories up and you felt it but they they
just they just tell you how to do it you
just fall basically you you fell back
where I jumped out of a helicopter
before but not not backwards yeah the
hard part about that was if you see
there's two rails on the helicopter and
uh I had to go down to that second rail
because I was tall and it was the blades
are right over your head and getting
down on that second I thought on this is
how I'm going in I'm gonna slip and
you're flying over the Red Sea while
they push you send you out it's going
fast
when you fell backward no they were
stopped okay okay but when I went out
onto the rail we were still in motion we
were still moving wow did anybody not
able to do it was anyone like I can
there were people heard there were
people heard there's people that hurt
when they hate Madison got hurt yeah
when he hit the water she hit the water
and she ended up in the hospital in the
bed next to me because of that injury uh
she also had dehydration heat exhaustion
but that injuries to you guys
you did but the water was also 110
degrees and it was hard to get and you
only got to it occasionally you know we
had canteens and stuff but if our
canteens weren't full at all times
they'd punish the whole group
like not even being um not even being
they could never have done this in this
country ever so somebody could have
actually died not even being uh you
should see this some of the stuff we
were doing yeah oh yeah pretty easily
yeah
they did at New Zealand apparently just
now yeah wow yeah we're all dying to
know how it was and would you change the
experience we'll show back
outside of any of the hospital
um uh that guy that guy Remy delicate
you guys should get him in here
interview him he's an amazing that guy
he's the instructor he's one of them
he's an amazing human Nigerian guy uh
how the father was assassinated came
here grew up in then in Bronx mother two
sons no money after being in luxury in
Nigeria they go bad he sees he sees a
movie about the Navy Seals and what I I
I got to do that he was already
he was into gangs he was selling drugs
he was doing stuff and he goes to the he
goes the recruiter and they go you you
have two felonies two different states
Jersey and New Jersey what are you
talking about and Navy SEAL is a big
deal he's like I want to do this the
recruiter took him to the judge in both
States got him an exemption became a
Navy SEAL Navy SEAL intelligence officer
Navy SEAL instructor that's an awesome
story and he lives in the New York area
he travels around he lives in San Diego
but he's he's doing stuff
that's an awesome show I want to watch a
show like that yeah it was a great show
and so anyway so we're all bonded we're
all close friends now and would I go
back uh I he would have I have a hard
time saying no let's put it that way but
some of it is you're so it's such a
Stockholm syndrome they pull you in to
their world so tight that you'll do
anything they tell you how long was the
production it's like 10 days only four
people made it the 10 days though really
yeah and did you have to like but at
night you went and you got to speak to
your no oh no no no no no no no no speak
to your family all you saw with the
trainers no producers no nothing
everything's wired up cameras are all
wired everywhere occasionally you see a
drone occasionally there'd be a camera
in the water that's a real experience it
wasn't like oh they would go back to our
luxury hotel oh no every second you
didn't sleep usually or they kept you on
watching stuff all night and they'd
attack and the stuff was going on you
did this because why
I'm just trying to understand what you
did someone put a gun to your head to do
this no here's what happened this is
about back to your point about uh
Fitness and stuff I was I have recurred
Diverticulitis and at that point I had
multi it's horrible and I had multiple
attacks I was feeling weak and shitty I
was feeling old at that time and they
came to me and I like laughed at him I
go where are you gonna send me to Utah
or something there you know Jordan I'm
like oh come on how am I going to do
that and uh I went all right let me
think about it and I went out and I
started training running like sprinting
Hills and stuff like really training
hard and I started feeling great I
started feeling really good I thought
well maybe this is what I need something
to really a goal to work on and I'll do
this thing and um
it was a good thing for me wow that's
awesome man that's pretty awesome
because I think a lot of people like I
get that email I'm immediately saying
absolutely not there's no way I can do
it no no no no no if I show the subject
line well I I would over I would argue
that over 50 probably shouldn't be doing
this because because stamina wise and
strengthwise everything I was fine I was
into it but I'm older and so the
dehydration got me without my even
knowing it wow and the Heat and stuff I
became confused I was out of my head
right and it took me a while to come
back five liters of IV fluid before it
gets down you came back and kept with
the vigorous activity no no no no you
went they that was the really the sad
part for me is they go once I put an IV
in your arm you're out of here wow that
sucks
you were not one of the four that made
it
I was out fast I was outside humiliating
and sad because I that's humiliated just
saying yes to that is um already by that
point uh they were did they did some
late night abuse you know they had them
crawling in mud and through tunnels and
stuff at 11 o'clock at night when I was
back in the medic and I heard them
crying I heard the women crying and
screaming and stuff and I started crying
I was like I should I should be out
there with them those are those are
that's my grooves
so fast that happens it's crazy because
you know I know we got to get you out of
here but what do you think because
everyone talks about ozempic now and all
the negative news what do you think do
you think do you kind of go back to what
Dr Peter attia said and said forget all
that stuff just vigorous exercise Eat
Right do whatever you can but people
can't I I look I've been practicing
medicine long I've known that people
just won't or can't can't because of a
mental who knows I desived and trying my
whole career to you know figure out what
that something is but people have real
real trouble doing it and if and their
people have problems where I've got to
get that weight off them I I have
prescribed it I have prescribed it and
it works uh I'm worried about the side
effects I'm worried about the muscle
mass loss and stuff but there are times
when you you got to give people a leg up
and works and so I'm not going to
withhold it from them if yes of course
it's better just to vigorous exercise
and manager you have an excellent diet
of course people seem to even they can't
do this time so this you think is I
blame big food and big everything for
that look at the Temptation we get yeah
I mean it's not people's fault we we
make everything yummy and addictive and
that's that's the world we live
and you have to a guy had to cut out
carbohydrates so you asked me I never
answered your question what do I miss or
what you ask me something like that I
miss Pizza I miss donuts and I miss
pastries I mean you don't even take a
bite of them I will every once in a
while but I try to go long periods of
time like once a long period of time
with six months six months
not even cauliflower crust I I I may do
that now that I'm doing this
intermittent fasting and I'm
successfully losing some weight because
that is still plenty of carbs let's go
don't kid yourself there's plenty of
carbs in those in those cauliflower
crusts there's no there's no magic work
around there really isn't what's your
day of eating today let's just go
through Dr Drew's daily I probably I
probably will make it breakfast coffee
and cream in the morning and I'm not
hungry now and I'm doing great you know
1 30 in the afternoon but the cream
broke your fast technically yeah and and
so I do a little bit of you know
monkeying and I would probably get some
Starbucks if I have time down in the you
know at the World Trade Center okay and
um and I will probably have some uh bone
broth uh in the afternoon like four
o'clock where do you get that I use this
company called uh paleo Valley okay oh
my God they're bone broth this is so
good I'm suck it out of like a like a
juice no it's a powder poem Rod that I
put in coffee and uh and then we will go
out to dinner and I will be cautious of
my choices but I will eat you know
because I once I start at that point
like what do you think you'll eat like
I'm gonna hope I'll either I might order
a steak tonight but I but I tend to try
to or a small steak and then what will
the sides Be and I will have some some
spinach and I will have creamed
hopefully not but it'll be tempting
it'll be tempting and hopefully just a
salad you can't cream in it you don't
even have a prostate I can't I can't
what do you think about that
um I I could you text me from now on
everything you eat in a day and I will
mimic you and then see where we land yes
I'm able to but no I will not okay
baby so Dr Joy after dark uh what else
doctor oh there's my alarm because I
want to make sure I stop because I could
talk to you guys all day trust me yeah
no I would talk to you all day man I
would we could go another hour no
problem I'll come back yeah I will come
back I'm back in a month or so to the
city and I will put you we'll do a good
one taste buds you can do Christy chaos
we got a whole thing what's what's the
taste buds is uh it's uh Sal's podcast
with Joe DeRosa where they debate food
so he'd be perfect for that oh my God
yeah knock knock them down drag them out
fights about the simplest things like
everything bagel versus cinnamon raisin
we get into shouting matches but it's
fun it's all in good fun okay I'm sure I
want to be a part of that yeah okay but
um yes I will be back no for sure uh and
thank you for getting me out of here
because I do have to run up tonight but
just real quick before we go TV is where
you can see the streaming show with all
the stuff the all the if you if people
have been silenced I'm talking to him
but I do talk to other people sorry
Megyn Kelly we talked a lot of stars and
stuff there too right uh and then uh
after dark is really what I'm here to
promote over at your mom's house because
this is an audience I would love after
our Chris was on you got to come do it
yeah we did we do it in Austin every six
weeks or so and um and then doctor.com
I've got everything there Adam and Drew
Drew more in the Drew podcast the more
with professionals and scientists and
things but Adam and Drew we still are
together after all these years and then
real quick before we get you out of here
just real quick one two three we do an
fmk you know Harry kill for you Dr Dr Oz
Dr Phil Dr Martin Luther Dr Martin
Luther King okay
[__] marry kill Dr Oz Dr Phil Dr Martin
Luther King I already know where he's
going with it but Oz is a personal
friend and a guy I admire greatly I mean
I really really admire the guy he he was
the head of cardiovascular surgery at
Columbia Presbyterian Hospital that is
one of the highest positions in the
country that's who that guy is marrying
him
Dr Martin Luther King doctor [__]
Martin Luther King
I love that guy too I really do love him
but uh
I don't know him so I have the same warm
feelings that I have for us and I have
to kill that I love it Dr Joe Everybody
follow him everywhere I love that sound
bite this has been hey babe
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey babe
[Music]